ce soir ultime fait new je trouve que la
ville de québec est bien plus belle que
la ville de montréal
c'est vraiment bien fait dans un monde
où la désinformation de masse inquiète
l'intelligence artificielle permet
maintenant de créer des faux presque
plus vrai que nature aux roms posent
autour d'un couple d'options we need to
be moins vite rejoint côtoient ou trois
premières
bienvenue dans l'univers des des fakes
un monde où n'importe qui puisse faire
plusieurs puis son corps et sa voix
laminage penser l'ips plus possible de
croire en fait ce qu'on voit on pourrait
se retrouver avec des vidéos très
crédible avec le petit logo de radio
canada ou le logo de cnn qui ont été
complètement trafic et qui ont l'art
extrêmement creed
[Musique]
ces discours de barack obama passera à
l'histoire
non pas en raison de son contenu ce
discours d'obama est historique parce
qu'il ne l'a jamais prononcé poznan
trump aux autres on voit barack obama on
entend l'ancien président mais il s'agit
d'un des fake
selon le terme désormais consacré dans
le vocabulaire techno un des faits que
c'est une vidéo complètement fausse
créée au moyen de l'intelligence
artificielle
ce nouveau seuil des 10 mars
moi je retiens c'est le réalisateur qui
a réussi ce trucage d'obama aux
promeneurs
son but était d'alerter le public ou
dérives potentielles du procès dit
qu'obama c'était une prise de conscience
qu' on était face à quelque chose qui
était potentiellement très dangereux
dans notre rapport à la démocratie
[Musique]
ici sur la promenade des célébrités à
los angeles
on déambule dans un monde d'illusions de
fou et de pacotille mais dans la mecque
du cinéma américain on est aux premières
loges pour rencontrer des étoiles du
domaine de l'animation et de
l'intelligence artificielle qui ont
développé des outils aussi fabuleux que
dangereux
nous sommes ship in spring studio de los
angeles pour rencontrer l'un de ses
nouveaux maîtres de l'illusion pas ce
que je vais faire le projet prendre une
photo de moi même nous y avons rencontré
paoli vrai poste docteur en sciences
informatiques et fausses danseuses de
gangnam stade il me prête son visage et
je lui prête ma voix
alors saluons je suis très très heureuse
de te rencontrer rencontrer toute ton
équipe
je suis ici chez pin screen vous faites
vraiment du boulot un peu inquiétant
mais très réaliste et très sophistiquée
avec sa jeune entreprise ils brassent de
vrais gros à faire dans le domaine du
faux le but qu'on a en fait ceux de
créer une technologie qui permet en fait
des gens de communiquer en 3d dans le
futur il ya aussi de créer en fait des
abattoirs
en 2013 à oli a contribué un trucage
historique
quand le comédien paul walker est mort
dans un accident de voiture en marge du
tournage du film fast and furious
les producteurs ont voulu le ramener à
la vie ils ont demandé à ses frères qui
lui ressemblait déjà beaucoup de prendre
la relève pour ensuite remplacé leurs
visages par celui de bowker mois en
particulier juste position de tracking
au fait du visage de son frère donc lié
sait que vous avez des caméras qui a
filmé son frère sur les scènes pour fait
ce qu'on doit capturer en fait si ces
mouvements en 3d
une manière vraiment très précise et
en fait un usage réel photoréaliste à
l'époque une telle prouesse
technologique demandé des moyens
considérables mais ce n'est plus le cas
et là où ses possibilités deviennent
plus inquiétante
c'est qu'on peut maintenant plusieurs
pays l'image de n'importe qui grâce à
une photo prise sur internet
kim jon ouais je pense que le truc qui
est vraiment nouveau ici c'est que tout
ce qu'on a besoin c'est vraiment juste
une seule image on peut faire les images
c'est vrai quelque chose qui est
vraiment accessible quelque chose qui
est vraiment facile d'obtenir sur
internet soulager besoin d'une image et
on peut on peut créer un fake news en
temps réel dans cette version encore en
développement
la coiffure trahi la supercherie mais
penguin travaillent à résoudre ce
problème sont bonnes ça vous va très
bien donc on peut mettre la photo de
justin trudeau sur n'importe qui sur
n'importe qui sur vous même c'est
tellement simple et rapide et ça
fonctionne avec à peu près toutes les
photos disponibles sur le web
c'est très bizarre essayez peut-être la
mairesse de montréal valérie plein on va
ici et voilà
mais c'est sans moi de vous je préfère
dire quelque chose de pas crédible comme
je trouve que la ville de québec est
bien plus belle que la ville de montréal
et puis je suis jalouse de régis
labeaume qui est le maire de la plus
belle ville du québec
c est impressionnant c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment bien fait et on s'imagine
les conséquences ou le leu tolix ça
créerait nécessairement puis j'imagine
comment moi et mon équipe on essaierait
de dire non non ce pauvre est et tout ça
puis moi je me pose la question comment
on fait pour faire la contre preuve même
imaginer jusqu'où un politicien pourrait
se retrouver dans l'embarras en raison
d'un diptyque ce qui me ferait pas aussi
celles utilisées à des fins pour créer
la commentaires dans la chicane si je
peux dire ou venir appuyer des je sais
pas moi ça me faisait dire des propos
racistes par exemple choisir je sais si
c'est horrible
mathieu duguay les journalistes et
animateurs techno à radio canada il
s'intéresse au phénomène
on pourrait se retrouver avec des vidéos
très crédible avec le petit logo de
radio canada ou le logo de cnn ou le
logo de france 2 il a de voir des vidéos
circulent et qui ont été complètement
trafiqués et qui ont l'art extrêmement
crédible le cauchemar ce serait une
vidéo de tram qui dit avoir lancé une
attaque nucléaire sur la corée du nord
avant même qu'on se rende compte que
c'est un trucage on serait en pleine
guerre nucléaire ça peu de chances de se
produire mais c'est possible
chose certaine la technologie existe
elle annie farid se spécialise en
analyse et en authentification des
contenus numériques
n'importe qui peut créer des trucages
convaincant je pense que ça va mener à
une apocalypse que l'information
l'édifice ne sont pas qu'une menace à la
démocratie
les trucages sophistiquées peuvent avoir
un effet dégradant pour des
personnalités publiques en particulier
les femmes
ça a commencé dans la pornographie et
donc on a pu voir par exemple le visage
de michelle obama
plaquée sur une actrice afro-américaine
actrice pornographique afro américaine
les actrices emma watson cameron diaz
entre autres en ont été victimes leur
visage collé à d'autres corps dans des
positions sexuellement explicites
évidemment à leur insu en inde une
journaliste denquête critique envers le
pouvoir a aussi été victime de ce
traitement dégradant le dip fait qu est
devenue virale et en irak où une
élection se prépare pour le printemps
prochain des femmes candidates ont été
victimes de la mise en circulation de
vidéo sexuellement explicites
d'elle-même on sait les femmes les
personnes publiques sur des politiciens
on est plus vulnérable face aux
perceptions aux opinion publique
défavorable la critique est souvent
beaucoup plus acerbes plus rapide
le jugement est plus rapide l'une des
candidates irakienne a choisi de retirer
sa candidature même si elle affirme être
victime d'un trucage
même pour moi c'est difficile de dire si
ça a été fabriqué ou pas il ya des
artistes que
on voit souvent mais y'a tellement de
compression qu'on peut pas voir mais si
les gens ils ne savent pas que c'est
possible au fait de manipuler des des
vidéos comme ça de nos jours c'est
quelque chose de vraiment grave quoi
même si ces images sont fausses on se
retrouve avec des compositions vidéo de
soi qui tourne en ligne et que les gens
regardent et qui prennent ça pour du
cash de même si on arrive à prouver que
ces points de vue image l'image de
circuler plus les gens vont nous
regarder organes et notre visage collé
sur une actrice pornographique ou
d'autres ou dans des situations
dégradantes
ce qui est inquiétant c'est que ça
n'arrive plus qu'aux personnalités
publiques
une jeune étudiante australienne a vécu
un véritable enfer
on a greffé son visage à des images
pornographiques à de nombreuses reprises
ça a commencé lorsqu'elle avait 17 ans
quand nelson me one après six ans elle
trouve encore des vidéos dégradantes
d'elle-même
malgré une loi qui criminalise
maintenant ce geste plus
je me douche et la raconter son
cauchemar street journal il faut s'y
préparer les outils sont plus
accessibles qu avant ils se
perfectionnent 116 ce qui va rendre les
trucages de plus en plus difficile à
déceler
parce qu'on vous a montré de fausses
images mais ne serait ce pas encore plus
surréaliste si on pouvait imiter la voix
on est déjà rendu la live d'une jeune
entreprise de montréal a développé des
outils qui permettent d'imiter la voix
une technologie qui peut faire de belles
choses comme permettre à une personne
rendue muette de communiquer avec son
ancienne voie comme pour cet homme
atteint de sclérose latérale
amyotrophique aussi appelée la maladie
de lou gehrig
[Applaudissements]
comme personne vous pouvez faire le test
vous même et générer votre propre voix
artificielle en enregistrant un minimum
de 30 phases le système analyse la voie
pour en dégager les caractéristiques
plus vous lisez de phrases plus le
résultat se rapproche de votre voix nous
avons testé l'outil en lisant une
centaine de phrases pour le moment le
système ne fonctionne qu'en anglais et
le résultat est plutôt robotique s'est
pas entièrement convaincu pour le moment
c'est un logiciel gratuit disponible sur
internet mais se perfectionne assez
rapidement et après la pause on va
rencontrer des gens qui détecte les
fausses voit rester là
[Musique]
évidemment ça s'impose
just came en sont convaincus que ça va
arriver
il est maintenant possible d'usurper la
voix de personnalités publiques en
reprenant leurs discours par exemple
verser nuance une entreprise
internationale qui oeuvre dans le
domaine de l'intelligence artificielle
développe une technologie qui permet de
différencier le vrai du faux
l'imitation de la voix c'est une
technique qui est utilisée par les
fraudeurs depuis très très longtemps
mais aussi on est en mesure de détecter
des attaques beaucoup plus sophistiqués
tels que les voix synthétique dont je
vais vous montrer une voix synthétique
de très haute qualité au curry bon vous
voyez alors est lui-même
on dirait que c'est une voie à réel
c'est très convaincant c'est très très
convaincant par contre les algues sont
en mesure de détecter qu'effectivement
c'est une voix synthétique
si je vous demandais de répéter une
phrase sans fois vous allez toujours
parce que vous êtes un être humain vous
allez toujours en avant une variation
naturelle d'indication de membres un
ordinateur de le faire via un patin qui
se répète
et c'est comme ça qu'on dit en mesure de
détecter que c'est une voix synthétique
des manipulations de voix qui interfère
avec la démocratie
ça existe déjà en 2012 un politicien
colombien a été accusé d'avoir collaboré
avec les farc
ce qui l'a conduit en prison cette vidéo
est saoulé la série s qui était de la
fiscalité par application iphone puisque
c'est une impasse idiot et cole south et
bilan c'est la technologie de nuances
qui a permis de démasquer la supercherie
c'est grâce à notre logiciel qu on a pu
prouver qu'elle est la vidéo était
fausse
il y avait une motivation politique
mais dans l'avenir on pourrait voir que
un citoyen qui tient différentes
adresses avec son voisin a pourrait
utiliser des technologies qui vont
devenir de plus en plus disponibles a
pour créer du fait du fait que nous sur
cette personne là si la technologie de
nuance peut détecter les faux elle peut
aussi identifier les vrais
enregistrements il ya des vidéos
effectivement qui ont été analysés par
notre logiciel par les services de
l'homme qui ont permis de prévenir des
acteurs monsieur bernanke n'a pu nous en
dire davantage mais tout porte à croire
qu'il s'agit du terroriste
il avait enregistré une vidéo qu'il a
fait circuler dans les milieux
extrémistes et la police a fait
authentifie sa voix ce qui a permis de
conclure avec certitude que c'était bien
lui
résultat on a pu l'intercepter juste
avant qu'il ne mette à exécution son
projet d'attentât il a fait détoner sa
ceinture d'explosifs au moment de
l'opération policière
c'est un exemple saisissant de l'utilité
de créer des outils d'identification des
voix de façon beaucoup plus courant en
ce moment les technologies de nuances
servent surtout à détecter les fraudes
bancaires parce que les criminels
tentent aussi d'imiter les voies
cependant les gens dans le domaine du
crime organisé qui vont utiliser ces
technologies là pour voler votre votre
agent vous appelez à votation financière
on vous demande souvent votre nom votre
adresse
le solde de votre compte
peut-être d'autres informations mais
toutes ces informations sont disponibles
sur le coin et les fraudeurs sont en
mesure de nous dans ce domaine de la
faune pour faire échec à la fraude des
institutions financières ont maintenant
entrepris d'échantillonner la voix de
leurs clients des services anti fraude
au sein des entreprises ont investi dans
les technologies des nuances pour
prévenir septembre
à mesure que les technologies sera fine
des pistes de solutions sont aussi mises
de l'avant on a des intelligences
artificielles qui sont capables de
repérer si un pixel a été changé dans
une photo et donc ça serait assez
puissant pour reconnaître que la photo
ce serait une fausse
on peut aussi avoir des techniques de
photographie traditionnelle par exemple
si les ombres nos cadres poste si par
exemple une lumière qui éclaire les
pôles de la personne et que le visage du
poème éclairé de la même manière que la
lumière qui éclaire les pôles ce
pourrait être un signe qu'on y fasse un
audit fake et donc on est on est face à
une technologie qui est en train
d'évoluer
mais peu importe les avancées
technologiques
tous les intervenants qui nous avons
parlé s'entendent pour dire que dans un
monde de fausses nouvelles
les gens vont croire ce qu'ils veulent
croire le vrai problème c'est même pas
ses algorithmes je pense que le problème
c'est beaucoup dans nous
de nos jours il suffit de dire quelque
chose que les gens ils veulent y croire
pour propager des informations
vraiment un niveau ou à
y'a pas moyen de contrôler en fait j'ai
des doutes sur la capacité déjà investir
les fables nouvelles des six oui ou non
par une nouvelle
une vidéo est réel ou non le problème
c'est notre propre volonté de croire
n'importe quoi
dans ce monde d'illusions on ne le
répétera jamais assez il sera toujours
préférable de se tourner vers des
sources fiables love crédit au canada
des anars foetus très récemment le
canada à modifier la loi électorale pour
interdire les fausses vidéos comme edith
fakes se sont produites dans le but
d'influencer le résultat d'une élection
on parle d'image ou de vidéos qui tente
frauduleusement de faire croire qu'elles
sont authentiques et cette période
d'interdiction elle vaut pour la période
électorale mais aussi pour la période
pré électorale qui commence le 30 juin
prochain
[Musique]